punctuated of course by Sunday's Heritage
Classic at Commonwealth Fox to Lind takes it
hard to the hole save Stewart Skinner rebound
loose and shot wide in the mix paner rifles a
pass through lafranier and punched out SackMan
attacking he back treding to Center Philip helel
channeling his inner defenseman turned it over
quick chance jum off the side of net from Warren
Fogle and pulled back by Jonathan Quick BR
thought there might have been a trip on Dy
none forthcoming shot in by Fox and he got buried
by Kane he swept that in thrown in front Skinner
back door play Taco could not find trer blocker to
the half wall by Skinner and Ryan a clear to the
activating Brett kulak on his backand rid behind
that beautiful pass and a backhander stopped by
quick through a screen against Leon D Cal minute
to go in the period tro up the right hand side g
mark back to the RO Block Run year on the attack
C what a sh Stewart scner flashing out the right
P two onone here's gie little chip off the wall
it was EOL aggressively going down trying to keep
that play alive in the last minute three of the
last four meetings a team leading by three goals
has actually lost the hockey game well in that
first period we built up the firework aspect of
this Louie but shot suppression at a premium
for both hockey clubs soft chip came back to
him on a deflection P appearing inside out to
Fox One timer aand save by Skinner he's got to
reach back after extending from left to right and
he flashes theot Away by Kul Fox over to man yet
across to Panera shadowed by Conor Brown inside
Thro check one timer scor beautiful feed across
and the directional placement that time upstairs
from Adam Fox he guided that one in Lou and it's
one nothing the shot stor it's how you get it
to the net but this passes a beauty across and
it's one back one touch pass you can see for Fox
he was waiting for this chance opportunity and
look it it's a wide open he knows sk's going to
come across he knows he has to elevate it so he
takes a little off of it to make sure he elevates
stick to Side by Jonathan Quick and the Rangers
are away here's a ro went down and skman glov save
on L rier who tried to go upstairs on him the ERS
look to go to work on the for check dur beats
his man of the pop kako a cloud left point shot
save made quick rebound another stop quick Point
Blank dulak angles off the boards duen Hopkins
to Hyman takes it hard behind the goal reference
save quick and the rebound covered as kulak came
busting down the seam Adam Fox up the center sends
the others back Holloway with a clear Fox off to
Jimmy VC Rangers stay on side Schneider reach got
score two nothing [Music] they'll take a look at
it but I think that was called correctly at live
speed I don't know whether you had a better look
Lou it was very close into the play and here it
is here as this puck in the neutral zone you can
see goodro trying to get off the bench his feet
are off the ice so yeah he's fine there nice pass
across and the defender once again coming right
down Main Street I mean this is a pick corner by
Schneider so he kind of goes across the ground R
and this is it R o boy that was really close maybe
want to look at that a different angle I mean this
is right on it but another perfect shot through a
Defender that's going down trying to block it and
he picks the far side on Stuart Skinner we talked
to Schneider this morning it's hard to tell
on that play whether or not it comes all the
way out but he buries it the Rangers have given
up only one third period goal all year troch to
Wheeler fires off the post rebound down stayed out
during his tenure in Winnipeg seven consecutive
20 goal seasons for Blake wheeler Fox had buting
down the seam to the net with a backand to n by
Skinner two and a half to go in the period Guston
Twirls it back Savanah jet Schneider Savanah jet
one timer off the post that's twoo close and that
one went off the inside of the post and the Oilers
perhaps fortunate not to be further behind at this
juncture Rangers looking for more every shift up
the ice they creting those chances great east to
west pass and a one-time by Zan had the shooting
mentality and he ripped that one he was ready to
shoot it good pass by Schneider and theyve done
a good job to move around the box of Edmonton in
front of the golender and Aaron one timer score
threading it through and laugh rier buries it for
a three nothing lead and that's four four straight
games against Edmonton that La ronier has scored
you can see the reaction of steuart Skinner he's
moving from post the post on all of these chances
and one finally goes through is this Blast by laf
reier and guess who the bread man who's really
started to find that puck on a string in the
offensive zone allowing those guys to thrive as
they get into their third fourth and fifth Seasons
yep elevating them up the lineup giving them more
of a responsibility more ice time and wide ranging
Vinnie D able to eat that puck up but now briskly
moving it Forward dropping it for Hyman heading
for the neet shot and that might have ticked the
post quick able to cover lot of traffic in front
of Jonathan Quick on that one EC unable to hack
it out F inside what a same quick Point Blank and
again Conor Brown victimized a clown on the ice
wins the face off Bri shot off quick from theas E
shovel back behind the net for brown you can see
that cross coming and crumbled him in the power
play for the Rangers paner saan J paner R shot
save getner another interior pass the Rangers
able to get on top of it DC with Fogle keeping it
alive throw it in front open down Jonathan Quick
a second time in this period work here by both
M cloud in the first battle the backtracking by
fobal strip the puck get it into the middle and
Hyman has a real good look he tries to go glove
and the grizzled veteran denies it kolak hard up
the right hand side the Rangers break it up Ki
has a in it's wheeler in on net puts the brakes on
feathered it back and it was deflected home by kie
for his second the Oilers feel like this may have
been kicked in one in the neutral zone turns the
Puck over kie gets it to Wheeler good job by atom
to close and deny the chance but then throws it
into the middle and as he's going oh yeah there it
is there goes off the skate I don't think that's
a kick that's a kicking motion or just a kicking
motion stopping good goal I think that's the right
call I mean it's a little bit of a back kick
it's almost a soccer play through your legs but
not a forward motion I mean he's got his back
to the net by the time it does go in it'll be
cooie from wheeler they might actually take
a longer look at this one cuz there was some
motion towards the net with the foot after
video review it was determined the puck was
kicked into the net we have no goall there you
go wow Schneider disrupts the cycle he trying
to melt the remaining time and he will with help
from paner and it's a shut out for Jonathan Quick
29 stops and the rain score all three of their
goals in the second period to win going away